oh what's your advice if i'm interested  in something and i lose interest very  quickly when i've tried a bunch of  things my perspective on this is it's no  different than kissing a bunch of frogs  until you find your prince all of us at  this point gone through friendships and  potentially relationships and the  reality is some new kid moves in fourth  grade you think you're gonna be friends  the first couple days are good and then  the third day she or he shows you that  they're not a nice person and you walk  away which is fine no different than  interests and passions i wouldn't beat  yourself up or over judge yourself just  because you didn't fall in love with  cooking or being a yoga teacher the  reality is you still haven't found it  that's awesome there's nothing wrong  with that you're getting judged by  people who've settled people who  themselves settled without exploring and  are subconsciously deploying  miserylove's company